well over television you're watching
people downplay China's role in
spreading the corona virus and
downplaying it at the beginning of lying
about it but on CNN that's not enough
they always go the extra step over there
some CNN contributors have practically
become emissaries for Beijing watch this
it was China that came to the rescue as
Italy shook sending medical personnel
nine pallets of ventilators
electrocardiograph s-- and tens of
thousands of mosques all desperately
needed by a healthcare system in crisis
and appreciated by italians stuck at
home singing china's prey europe had few
other options donald trump's america
first policy has seen a gradual
worsening of the transatlantic alliance
over issues like climate change trade
and most recently over Trump's failure
to consult Europe over the coronavirus
travel ban with China now stepping into
the global leadership role long
abandoned by the American president it's
almost unbelievable that they ran that
on the air it was just pure bootlicking
flacking for the communist chinese
government by the way if they ever take
over jeff zucker will be there serving
them